لم يُقتل جندي واحد على وجه الأرض نحن
ونحن نأسف لأنه اضطررنا إلى ذلك
ضرب الطائرات
لكن هذه الوسائل ألقت القنابل وألحقتها
لم يضرب الصاروخ أيًا من مقاتلي الرجل
لم يُجبر فاغنر على القيام بهذه الحملة.
عرف الجميع هدفه النهائي، هدف الحملة
كان لمنع الدمار
اخي وتقديمه للعدالة
هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين ليسوا ملكهم
الإجراءات المهنية الملتزمة
عدد كبير من الأخطاء خلال لدينا
توقفت عند اللحظة الأولى
اقتربت فرقة الاعتداء من مسافة 200 كيلومتر
ونشرت موسكو مدفعيتها
استطلاع للمنطقة وكان من الواضح أن في
هذه اللحظة سوف تراق الكثير من الدماء
فظننا أن المظاهرة
توجو
ماذا كنا سنفعل لقد كان لديها ما يكفي
وكان قرارنا بالاستدارة اثنين
أهم العوامل العامل الأول هو ذلك
أننا لا نريد سفك الدم الروسي
العامل الثاني ذهبنا للتظاهر
من احتجاجه